[Music]
make your choice saw 10 is the
terrifying prequel we didn't know we
needed it takes place between the first
and second movie so we've got Amanda
returning with an all-new all creepy pig
mask and the somehow touching backstory
of what brought jigsaw to life so on the
off chance that anyone here isn't
familiar with the cultural phenomenon of
barberheimer it's the concept that you
go see two movies back to back that
premiered on the same opening weekend
Barbie and Oppenheimer is a great
example to compare because what saw X is
bringing to the table is well saw Patrol
yep you heard that right saw X and PAW
Patrol are coming to theaters at the
exact same time and yes a lot of people
will be partaking in this hilariously
timed double feature even though the saw
x movie poster is some sort of vicious
trap ready to annihilate a victim's
eyeballs and PAW Patrol is well a kids
movie these two films are only being
released on the same day in the United
States so other fans in places like the
UK will have to go see Paw Patrol and
The Exorcist for their double feature
leave me a comment below and let me know
how that goes so let's talk about run
times for these movies typically they've
all been about 90 minutes with the
longest run time saw 3 holding the
record at an hour and 48. the director
Kevin gruder said saw 10 is the most
epic installment of the franchise yet
and it's chock full of action from
beginning to end they didn't waste any
precious scenes in the editing room and
saw 10 now holds the record for the
longest running movie in the entire
series when we're editing a Saw movie we
do not waste time so the fact that it's
long I think is a testament to just how
well done it is
There Will Be Blood
so not only is the movie longer than the
rest but it's going to be the first one
in the franchise in a long time that
brings back the feel of the original
song movies
you'll have a lot of work that needs to
be done
it also helps that the timeline is set
in the earlier years more on that later
Kevin gruder admitted that on his first
directorial debut in the franchise
Sussex he just didn't have the
confidence that he has now I like to
think that we were all just much better
at it and more experienced and Tobin
Bell in particular has spent so much
time immersed in this character that
he's kind of fleshed out like I said a
huge part of the reason this is gonna
look and feel like the earlier Saw
movies is because sawtan takes place in
the timeline between the first and
second films they wanted this movie to
be easily digestible for people who
haven't seen the entirety of the saw
franchise it can also be watched as a
standalone so don't let the fact that
you haven't seen them all discourage you
from checking it out the goal was to
keep the film simple and straightforward
but they are making sure to answer some
long-standing questions that fans have
been asking about the series the
director hasn't touched on what happened
to Mark Hoffman at the end of Saw 3D yet
so that's one thing up in the air fans
are a bit anxious about looking at you
Kevin Sultan is being described as the
franchise's most personal story yet not
that having to cut off your foot or dig
around in a bin of syringes isn't
personal but this story has a bit of
heart to it the main plot point that
might surprise viewers is the humanizing
of John Kramer the back story is that he
travels to Mexico to try and receive an
experimental treatment for cancer but
when he returns to the United States he
learns that the whole thing was a scam
according to these scans
the tumor was never removed now this is
definitely a bit of a spoiler but it
goes with the personal backstory of the
film there's truly a reason whether it's
logical to us or not why John Kramer
does what he does you'll find out in the
film that a clinic gets held up at knife
point where John's wife essentially gets
forced to miscarry and it's tragic I'm
not sure if it's tragic enough for a
reverse bear trap but who am I to say
that's right before Jon gets his term
diagnosis so yeah our villains origin
story is in full swing we all pretended
to cure me soon after he ends up trying
to take his own life but he fails and
rediscovers his passion for living and
voila jigsaw is born but what I have
planned for each of you is very real you
could describe him as some sort of
alternative life coach with fatal
results
they actually did not only one but two
test screenings for this movie the first
one went so well the audience was truly
floored by it that they thought it had
to be a fluke they were like no way the
movie went over this well let's do a
surprise test screening to get a second
opinion so they waited until the very
last minute to reveal the location of
the second screening to hinder the
chances of bringing in an audience that
might be too friendly but it still
received the same Acclaim that it had
from the previous audience so yeah
apparently the movie is very good let's
talk about Amanda young real quick she
was a prominent figure in the first
three movies and gave us the Glorious
pig mask and robe combo that soon became
one of the most iconic horror villain
costumes something really exciting about
sawten she's back with a brand new pig
mask producers have revealed that Amanda
was always supposed to make a comeback
and that her presence is integral to the
plot considering this movie is set in
the earlier years of Saw we're gonna get
to see the relationship between she and
John unfold if you're truly unfamiliar
with Amanda's character she starts off
as one of John Kramer's victims and ends
up with a similar mindset to Jon at the
end of her trial she develops a newfound
love for life and essentially becomes
his Apprentice in his life coach
business eventually though she started
rigging her traps so her victims
couldn't get out of them which caused a
rift between her and Jon I'm curious to
see the in-between moments of their
relationship and how it ended up
developing that way a lot of fans were
wondering about whether or not Dr Gordon
would reappear for saw 10 because he
ended up escaping at the end of the
first Saw movie and wasn't seen again
until the Final Chapter now it's been a
hot topic of discussion whether he would
make a cameo of some sort but
unfortunately it looks like we won't be
seeing him again he's been quoted saying
a lot of things about the movie
particularly about his lack of
involvement in it but it was never
confirmed until recently I'm happy for
the filmmakers that they continue to
make money and that it seems to be a
financial bonus for them I really can't
speak to it because I'm not really
involved anymore but even though we
won't be seeing Dr Gordon again we do
get an exciting cast of fresh faces
we'll be seeing rhinatavaca from
Midnight family Paulette Hernandez from
crown of Tears Joshua okamoto from
control Z Octavio hinojosa from come
play with me cinema makoti Lund from
Ragnarok Stephen brand from the Sandman
and Michael Beach from Donner we've also
got Josh stolberg the writer from jigsaw
and Peter Goldfinger from spiral as the
screenwriters spoiler alert there was an
exclusive clip shown at the midsummer
scream featuring The Trap that's in the
movie poster I'm not gonna go into too
much detail because it's a little too
gory from a YouTube guidelines but I'll
give you the gist basically the Trap is
connected to the dude's eyes and fingers
they were told to choose which of the
two they wanted to keep
no big deal right so yeah moving the
dial up snaps a finger back one by one
but unfortunately he runs out of time
and his eyes are sucked right out of his
sockets total bummer so yeah that should
give you a bit of an idea of what we're
dealing with here on this next
installment no shortage of Gore let's
talk about the inspiration behind some
of these traps and rigs a lot of the
time it comes straight from the script
what's on the page is what's shown on
the camera but sometimes it's a bit more
nuanced Kevin talks a little bit about
how they come up with these things I
have lots of books on medieval torture
machines and other dark stuff and
sometimes we just pour through it and
shoot ideas off each other just
casual Day at the Office shooting ideas
back and forth about medieval torture he
also said when it came to the stuff they
were doing on saw 10 he got really
really nervous from a safety perspective
he also was concerned that things would
look super ridiculous once it was
actually all put together they did a lot
more testing on this movie than the
other movies they ended up having to
split the shoot into two parts three
weeks in November and three weeks in
January because everything was just so
complicated they had to make an insane
amount of Prosthetics and machines and
they spent pretty much the entire
Christmas holiday just working on that
stuff four fans of the franchise this is
some very exciting news it looks like
saw 10 is not the end Kevin is ecstatic
to see how this movie mulls over with
audiences if it's successful it's very
likely that we would get another one
there's no obvious new direction to go
after this film but I think there
probably will be more Saw movies
particularly if this one is successful
so the reason why there's no obvious New
Direction is because of this film's
heavy Reliance on the past which I'm not
complaining about I want answers Kevin
teases that there are a lot of surprises
in store for fans as well as a lot of
you guessed it answers he described it
as something like a storytelling
cul-de-sac it's more about building more
on what's in the past rather than
planting seeds for the future rather
than planting seeds for the future so
truly this franchise could go anywhere
after this saw 10 delivers horrifying
new traps a brand new cast to torture
and answers to long time questions fans
have been itching for judging from the
two successful test screenings and the
nightmare of a snippet that was shown at
mid-summer scream it looks like this
next saw installment is one you're not
gonna want to miss